non-minimalists
what are your thoughts on the difference
between guilt and shame
being a primary trigger to lead someone
to become
addicted to porn you know i think it's
really fascinating and i have a
a article that we're going to talk about
on the maximal episode
um because i do think that
part of what's going on right now with
the the shame and
guilt around sexuality and thus
to porn has to do with we've been
acculturated to
be ashamed of our bodies of sex of
sexual expression right
how did you get over that because
especially the time when you started
it was a giant leap for you to have to
make and
did you ever struggle with guilt or
shame at all before or after
um i struggled with everyone else's you
know everyone else's guilt and shame was
projected on me to the point where
i can't tell you how many apartments i
was denied access
banks i was denied service you know in
the late 80s early 90s
as a girl in this industry taking money
into a bank there were women that would
just
not deal with you they would just send
you out so i dealt with
not feeling it myself because to me this
was my choice i just tell people like
you're letting this bother you and this
doesn't bother me i'm a sexual being
i had three very simple goals at 16
which was to travel and see the world
make my own money and make my own
schedule adult life
porn fulfilled that for me you know what
i mean i got to see the world so
the guilt for me is only when someone
projects it on me you know like
sometimes i remember in my dating life
like
i'd go on a date with somebody i think
they'd be really into me and then i
realized like oh they want me to explain
to them how i deal with my guilt
and i don't have any guilt which they're
going to be bothered by because they
have a ton of guilt
and they need me to pacify them so that
they can consider dating me
because really they just wanted to see
what it would be like and now that they
think they kind of like me they don't
know how to process the information
right
it's a very select person to process the
information
we shouldn't be ashamed of our bodies i
have a much more european mindset
whereas they're so
open in other countries we're so held
off that's why porn makes so much money
because if we
make people think it's it's bad then
they want it more like drugs alcohol
cigarettes what have you
um so for me it's not my guilt i mean
i've been
i've had especially during the pandemic
when the world was closed i sat down
with myself and said
how glad are you that you took every
[ __ ]
chance you could here we are sitting
locked in our places would
i have no regrets yeah i've had sex with
people in other countries that never
spoke english i worked in
on sets and in a whole room of people
that spoke different languages and our
only common language was sex
and i feel so liberated by these choices
that i made in these chances that i took
so people have to understand that you're
the guard of your own thoughts when it
comes to shame and guilt
criminals feel shame and guilt right
they're sitting in a cell and they have
to sit and think about what horrible
things they did
that got them there which is awful
sexually you shouldn't feel
shame or guilt let's talk about shame
versus guilt here
let's have a quick pity answer and then
we'll unpack it here
guilt tells us something about our
actions but shame says something about
our identity so ultimately if we do
something
you said as a criminal you might do
something once it doesn't make you that
person
you made a mistake or a bad decision
depending on
those those are two different things but
maybe you made a bad decision that
doesn't mean that's who you are as a
person
but if you're that person who continues
to rob bank after bank after bank you're
probably a bank robber
yeah right you're that person yeah yeah
and so ultimately you're going to feel
shame because that's who i've become
i've become this person well guess what
how do you change that shame it's by
stop doing the actions that created the
guilt that ultimately created
the the shame and now but what we're
talking about here is not of specific
action
sex isn't the thing that we should feel
guilty about humans have always done it
are we are we gonna act like that's not
something that's it's been happening for
200 000 years uh
plus uh in humanity and and so that's
not the thing to feel
guilty about what we feel guilty about
is this
this moralizing that has happened in our
society and
ryan and i we we have different beliefs
we have similar values though so we
bring a lot of different people on the
podcast the first time you were
scheduled to be on here
uh there were some co-vid related things
you weren't able to make it we had a uh
a pastor on that same day instead right
i even told i haven't told him that his
name is erwin mcmanus and uh but he's a
different kind of pastor who isn't a
moralizing sort of
person in fact the the church that he
started he didn't let christians come to
it for the first couple years
because they're too judgmental he was
afraid he was
because he he himself was a christian
because he was afraid that christians
were going to ruin
his chris his sort of christianity in a
way because he was he didn't want to be
judgmental he wanted to create
this thing for people who want to create
a space
of openness and i think that's what
we're talking about right now
we're talking about whether it's it's
porn or we're talking about
any of our other proclivities um we need
the space to even talk about these
things
and i think even a conversation like
what we're having right now can be
incredibly taboo for some people because
because of the guilt that they're
that they are feeling and it doesn't
mean that you have done something wrong
necessarily it means that you're
told the thing that you want is wrong
that your desire is wrong that your
human tendencies are
wrong but i don't think that gets us
very far no
yeah i think uh it's interesting because
growing up as a jehovah's witness they
are
kids are getting married at 17 18 years
old because they're not allowed
to have sex before marriage so they
don't want to live in sin so they end up
getting married and i can't tell you
how many of them end in divorce or worse
they're still married and can't stand
each other
so i mean it's it's uh it is so
important to question why we feel guilty
in fact
my pithy answer is this uh learning from
your guilt
can help you avoid shame so
if you watch porn and you feel guilty
that is a symptom of something and
you've got to ask yourself why do i feel
guilty is it because
i'm told i should feel guilty is it
because
i had this sexual experience without my
partner i mean to examine why
you feel guilty that's really what's
going to help you
move forward and then you learn from
that guilt either you learn something
about
your morals or you learn something about
uh
you'll learn something about yourself if
you don't learn from your guilt then you
will get to a point where you start to
be ashamed of who you are so the bank
robber who's robbing multiple banks
eventually is going to be like well
i'm a bank robber so that's what i'm
going to do accepted it yeah yeah and
they yeah
they reconcile with okay i have to
become now i am this person i've become
the sort of
the the bad guy i love what you're
saying here ryan about about
guilt because well i think in
uh where was i going to go with this
um there's so many ways to go with it
yeah yeah yeah
um so if if someone is feeling guilt
because the society has propped them up
some way we call it a a memetic belief
right it just means that society has
said something is
is wrong or taboo and
and we may not feel that intrinsically
that something is
is wrong or taboo and so
there's this cognitive dissonance now
lisa ann you were able to avoid that
cognitive dissonance in a way
and um how you i know you you mentor
younger i would call them kids now but
people in their 20s
they could be my children okay yeah and
many of them come to me because they can
have conversations with me
that they just don't feel comfortable
having with their parents or
friends their age i love having younger
friends because younger people keep you
so inspired i mean their level of
movement now they're so creative every
young kid knows how to edit
create do everything from a laptop like
you could take them to another country
and they'll put you out 10 youtube
videos you know what i mean like
the things they know how to do but yet
they haven't had those conversations
with their parents uh they're very
intimidated by porn
you know think about being a young woman
and trying to watch porn for your first
time
it's much more geared towards men than
it was when i started in the 90s there's
not a lot there for them then it makes
them afraid
oh are these things gonna happen to me
when i go to have sex with a guy
yeah so i'll tell young people for every
one porno scene
you watch i want you to read a romance
novel
because when i grew up all of my aunts
read these
romance novels and so eventually i took
one i realized
oh my gosh this is reading porn yeah
they're pretty steamy
they're so steamy they're so steamy and
yet but yet they get the juices flowing
right
but then there's a cliff because you
know you have to visualize your own sex
scene
but see that's a really good thing for a
young woman because if you take that
next step and you visualize the sex
scene you're almost creating what you
think turns you on
you're visualizing what this man would
look like how he would touch you
as you're reading this so i think we
need to kind of roll it back that's a
really good sex education
is playing the mental game with yourself
getting your heart racing a little bit
and feeling it
rather than they just go to it i mean
there's so much kissing talk in those
romance novels i was young i was like 10
i was like
why did my aunts read these things like
cover to cover and then i got it
we don't offer that in porn right now so
i think for me teaching young people to
roll it back
to be limiting what they're watching but
also to trust each other and to
want to touch and see how it feels you
know
when i was younger we were a little bit
freer we would have more experimental
sex
we would talk during it you know we
weren't as held back i think this
generation is a bit more scared to do
that because they're afraid it will get
out on social media
somebody might take a photo somebody
might tell a friend oh i was with him
and he couldn't get
it up they're so afraid of
their peers yeah we didn't have that who
was going to tell and if they did who
was going to believe
them right but back then people didn't
speak about it gossip about it they
respected it
yeah this this enhances the sort of
guilt ryan what you were talking about
earlier like
if you feel if you watch porn and you
feel guilty from it
um that that may be the case but the
guilt could stem from several reasons
sometimes the guilt might be justified
like when i talked about earlier my
first marriage
i should feel guilt for that because
what i was doing was hiding something
not that i was watching porn it wasn't
the porn that was the problem
in that relationship it was me and it
was our compatibility that was a problem
in that relationship and so i felt
guilty not
because of watching the porn then this
is just in retrospect but i felt guilty
because i was hiding something from
someone that
i loved and you weren't sharing your
needs with that person either you were
handling them on your own you felt very
selfish guilt about that
too absolutely because now you knew she
wasn't going to get taken care of either
so in the back your mind you had guilt
about that as well
yeah and so when i
when i finally came to terms with like
hey it maybe it's not
the porn that is the problem here
at least in that relationship it was
a lack of communication uh unwillingness
to be myself with the person who's
closest to me
and i was putting up a sort of facade
right
and so i think that and then eventually
the shame came in because like well i
guess i'm the type of person who goes
and like hides in his office and
masturbates to porn instead of having a
difficult conversation with my wife
that's that is a problem and that's when
porn becomes a problem but then now
in my marriage now it is
it's sort of an augmentation it's an
amplification
it's not a crutch we don't use it
regularly but
when it if even if we did that'd be fine
but what happens
is we use it when it's when it feels
appropriate
and decadent yeah yeah i love you know i
loved i loved when i was on the road and
i'd be at strip clubs and there'd be
couples that would come in
once a month they would go out for like
a nice dinner and then they'd go to the
strip club together and it was just
their thing
they did once a month and some of them
were really just people watchers right
but it was something they
shared that was so unique and it just
made me happy
in the late 90s when i started to see
couples evolving you know when i started
the owners didn't let women into clubs
so even if you were a couple
the owners back then would say well
these women will take away from my women
making money and they'll be fights over
these women i'm like no these are
couples
that want to come in and do this
together and maybe share in a dance and
talk about what they like in a girl and
then of course that you know they went
home and had great sex
right and finally this started to evolve
and it made me very happy because i
would see couples and the girls would
always treat them really well too
because the girls were like this is so
cool you guys are doing this together
and
it was it was their thing just like you
guys watching something together it was
just kicking it up a little notch
together yeah so if we were to sum this
up would we say that
porn is a problem when it when you
become dependent on it just like
or and or when it gets in the way of
living meaningfully
and that i think you could sub you could
substitute porn with alcohol
because it's not inherently evil right
uh you could substitute it with
work there are workaholics where that
just destroys their life
right but no one's saying well i guess
we should stop working now
because uh one guy happens to be
addicted to working no we what we need
to say is there's
a responsible amount that we need to
figure out that's appropriate for
our own lives and so the bad seems to
happen when it gets in the way or we
become dependent on it
the good happens when it enhances
amplifies our experience of life
i also think the bad happens when you
are too young
age plays a huge role in this i mean
under 18
haven't had any of your imagine your
first experience
is with a porn and not with an a girl
yeah
so i think it's age when it came into
your life and then how much free time
you had to watch it i think it being
accessible on phones
is really creating havoc and that's why
when he said mid 20s i was like
bing bing bing i know exactly what his
problem is he was locked in his room
watching it for endless hours a day for
probably
five ten years yeah and that creates an
unhealthy relationship
with other people because they're not
actually
uh you know you're not seeing them
necessarily as other people at that
point
right and you're not engaging no you're
not you're not engaging with other
people you're not going out flirting
with girls you're just sitting and
watching something that can be
really destructing and really disturbing
yeah and it can it can ruin you in a lot
of ways uh another thing dan savage
often says he talks about
death grip syndrome i was just thinking
that yeah i mean
i don't know if you're familiar with
this but basically it's you know
guys who masturbate so frequently
they're they're unable to
you know just get off with it with
another partner uh
and i think that what's happening is
your mind all of a sudden now associates
associates
horniness or attraction with that
glowing screen
as opposed to that other human being who
isn't everywhere the stunt people that
are acting like they're enjoying it
more than they actually are that it is
shot with a fisheye lens that makes the
guy
look larger than he actually is where
there's tons of lubricants to make the
girl look
wet like everything about it is
amplified like a stunt movie like a
stunt
so it's such an unrealistic you know
when i did my speech at oxford union and
i said 99
of what you saw on the internet don't
ever ask a girl to do any of that for
you
yeah you know it's not gonna happen and
you're most likely gonna offend her and
freak her out
so reel it in reel it in but there's so
much they see and i think
too young is very destructive yeah